what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation greg here joined by aaron
alexander aaron how are you doing buddy
oh i'm doing freaking great my boy my
boy my boy
my boy
young chap so i had a list of movies
here written down recommended
and apparently
i've never seen any tom hanks movies
that's what i've learned
in your entire life i watch forest gump
here green mile and uh between this
election i've been i've been feeling
like watching apollo 13 and this was the
one that you
said like let's watch this one and i was
like perfect that's what i've been
feeling like checking out so we're gonna
react to apollo 13 today if you can i
know you can leave a like that'd be very
much appreciated also subscribe and
click that notification bell to get
notified when we got a reaction up that
might fancy your interest following
through action watch long as we sync up
with your own copy over at our patreon
page for super sexy rejects cover a
bunch of shows exclusively over there
with reaction highlights and watch songs
included the team at prepper of course
thank you guys for helping us edit down
these highlights he followed the real
aaron alexander over on instagram and
he's gonna be started posting his poems
ticket to talk talk cop ticket to talk
walk to the shock
maybe tomorrow i can swallow
uh i can't end it all right
[Music]
there were serious doubts that we could
beat the russians to the moon the entire
world watched in awe as neil armstrong
and buzz aldrin landed on the moon what
it would have been like to be back
to be around for that man i'm crazy now
the important thing when you're
penetrating the lunar module is your
attitude and your relative speed now
let's say this is me here in the command
module and this is you
in the left this thing sticks out here
in front that's called a pro
and tracy i'll tell you when you feel
that thing slide
[Laughter]
60s baby
god how many movies has gary sinise done
with tom hanks i'm sure there's a
collection
jim you think it's too late for him to
board
no no he he still has time to get out
there just needs somebody to wave him
off
[Music]
38 year old american standing on the
surface of the moon
on this july 20th 1969.
ryan gosling did it people
first man
[Music]
that should have been me damn it
what emotion is he feeling
when you were on the far side on eight i
didn't sleep at all i just vacuumed over
and over again christopher columbus
charles lindbergh and neil armstrong
pioneers
where's my mountain
the white area there that's the sea of
tranquility and your mountain's right
there on the edge of that in your
mountain
i don't see it
go vacuum
[Laughter]
you know that easter vacation trip we
had planned for
i was acapulco
there might be a slight change in
destination
really
maybe say
the moon
we're going to the moon everybody
this easter egg
i gotta get over there we're gonna have
to get up to speed on this
go yeah
i'm gonna walk on the moon marilyn
i know i can't believe
it naturally it's 13. why 13. she's
going to be doing so much vacuuming
[Laughter]
okay s4b is stable slot panels are
drifting free the drogue is clear the
docking target is clear
i wonder how much of this they actually
like
were they able to use some real
pieces from nasa and stuff to put this
together
well i'm sure they let them use a good
amount i'm sure they collaborated with
them a little bit okay we're stable go
ahead and recycle the valves 40 feet
they're all gray
captured that's it
that's it
sweet move ken beautiful
my rate of turn is still a little too
slow there i really think we should work
it again
okay 13 backup crew it'll have to wait
prime cruise up for another run yeah
baby god that sounds boring
oh my god i can never be an astronaut no
too boring
yikes
is a dream sequence
[Music]
oh man this is scary i got scary nipple
chills
adjusting it here the attitude there
pitch roll
for a nice
soft
landing on the moon better than neil
armstrong
way better than pete conrad wow
explaining it to a kid is a very
efficient way to explain it to the
audience
they've never kept you from coming to
the other launch yes but now i have your
mother she's just had this stroke mom's
fine
honey it's not like i've never been to a
laundry before the other wives have not
done three
i just don't want to see you die okay
oh you're gonna miss a hell of a show
oh wow
that's a pretty realistic touch
[Music]
[Laughter]
now that's a realistic
why is this your last jim the best ship
with the best crew that anybody could
ask for
and i'll be walking in a place where
there's 400 degrees difference between
sunlight and shadow
i can't imagine uh
ever topping that also it's your
controlling wife
[Laughter]
it's a joke people i understand where
she's coming from
you you want to break up my crew two
days before the launch jim that's a
lousy time for a fever all right now
look jack swaggart has been out of the
loop for weeks he's fully qualified to
fly this mission he's a fine pilot but
when was the last time he was in a
simulator you can't break up the boys
i've trained for the fraumora highlands
and this is flight surgeon horseshit
[Laughter]
well i uh
damn
oh that really sucks man [ __ ]
look i don't have the measles
i'm not gonna get the measles
that really sucks
you imagine that
i got a card i like we're coming in too
shallow
i'm going to manual
this guy's too risky
placed by his own rules as a maverick
goddamn cowboy out here
well we have two days we'll be ready
let's do it again
who's really good at building up the
suspense of everything that could go
wrong
all the possible
whole idea of space travel just
terrifies me
[Music]
i heard it was gonna be a hell of a show
no who told you that
some guy i know
you can't live without me
[Laughter]
on the moon
could have saved a lot of time by
shaving in advance guys
no
oh
it sucks oh my god that's the worst
that's like my biggest fear the movie's
gonna be cutting back forth in the space
mission and her looking for the ring
that's just as much about her looking
for the ring
and the c story is the the journey of
the ring itself
the score so powerful
swelling
[Music]
i'm really enjoying this movie
jim you're all set
[Music]
after watching four seasons of westworld
it's really weird to see young ed harris
right now
i'm not used to think you have hair
launch control this is houston we are go
for launch
roger that houston
damn this poor guy
he has a nice car
yeah
this is it
a few bumps that we're hauling the mail
this movie does a good job at capturing
that wonder too
because it is something that like i
totally
take for granted like we can do this
like i know this already happened i feel
so tense right now
hey
[Music]
wow that's a hell of a shot wow yeah
yeah
i suggest it looks great
whoa
that doesn't look like cgi i can't tell
[Music]
the clock is running
[Music]
nipple chills
go to space people
this is exciting
[Laughter]
oh wow
[Music]
come on
there's some great effects in this
yeah
but the time it came out looks really
good yeah
no holds up really well
get ready for a little jump fellas
[Music]
that's a cool shot
is 13 we've got a center engine cut off
go on the other four
oh already
[Music]
can we hey have a word for you
remember thank you proud happiness
how are you feeling we're very proud and
very happy when we're thrilled
we're going to the moon
flight we have re-acquisition of signal
at hawaii yeah flat everything looks
like that's pretty much better than that
so much is involved in getting this one
thing to the boot
gonna go ahead and get set for
transposition and docking
roger that jack
ah girls even try covering your mouth oh
come on oh no dude come on
nasty
thrusting forward
100 feet
don't mess this up man the fact that
this movie set this [ __ ] up so early in
the beginning
you were nervous
stop staring at him
do something
come on rookie park that thing
10 feet
he's doing the metaphor
caption we have hard doc roger
understand
you guys should assume matthew
mcconaughey did an interstellar that was
way harder
[Laughter]
there's nothing
oh it's too bad we can't demonstrate
this on tv
wow is that really how they go to the
bathroom
here it comes
the constellation you ryan
what the hell
[Laughter]
that's really what they do
the whole movie was worth it to learn
that
i'm jim lovell and we're broadcasting to
you tonight from an altitude of almost
200 000 miles
away from the face of the earth and we
have a pretty good show in store for you
tonight still blows my mind this is the
60s which is like
so long ago and are capable of this back
then
all the networks dumped us
one of them said we made going to the
moon about as exciting as taking a trip
to pittsburgh
oh
my son's supposed to be on
he's in outer space
i've been accused of receiving all the
channels we get oh that is so sad so
they're performing for no one
well folks as uh you can probably tell
the aquarius isn't much bigger than a
couple of telephone booths man i really
think they're putting on a great show
which they are
this is the crew of the apollo 13
wishing everyone back on earth uh a
pleasant evening
that's cool this is a true story
i think
it's not another story i guess to be
told that's cool
give your oxygen tanks a stir
roger that
what the hell
[Music]
there's a demon on board the spaceship
it's the ring the ring did it
whoa
no
oh geez
hey we've got a problem here
you're way too chill about this kevin
bacon nothing i stirred the tank what
did you do
uh this is houston uh say again please
houston we have a problem ah they said
that oh [ __ ] that's where this is
oh
[Music]
cool
i don't know maybe this is a cautionary
warning houston
we are venting something out into space
i can see it outside of window one right
now what
a gas of some sort
it's got to be the oxygen oh my goodness
oh god we're not gonna have power much
longer
the ship's bleeding to death
wow what a hell of a shot we can isolate
it there and we can save what's left in
the tanks and we can run on the good
cell you close them you can't open them
again you can't land on a moon with one
healthy fuel cell the odyssey is dying
from my chair here this is the last
option
you were always so [ __ ] annoying sigh
my goddamn last nerves
[Laughter]
shutting down the fuel cells did i hear
you right yeah jim uh
oh my god survive guys
[Laughter]
screw the moon at this point you just
gotta live
we just lost the moon
damn it armstrong
[Laughter]
what exactly
what went wrong exactly
something exploded
[Laughter]
they didn't believe they didn't believe
strong enough they could do it it's law
of attraction problem man yeah yeah
how long does it take to power up the
limb three hours by the checklist we
don't have that much time
[Music]
so nerve-racking
[Laughter]
i don't like it
how much time can you give me a number
well we're looking at less than 15
minutes of life support in the odyssey
it's a great day in new york isn't it
it's girl watchers oh yeah i like those
ingenious girl wife aren't you
[ __ ] glad right now
[Laughter]
three million fewer viewers watched the
uh space shut than did the last one
uh i thought uh um colonel aborman is
here
at abc
ah dude apollo 13 is apparently also
losing breathing oxygen from the
astronauts electrical failure what
exactly does that mean the emergency has
ruled out any chance of a lunar landing
oh this is horrifying
[ __ ] i want to know what's happening
with my husband all right we want to
switch control to the aquarius now that
house is going to be so clean
stress cleaning
our rcs isn't up here yes we have no
attitude control on aquarius
they don't have control do we miss a
step here
control what the hell
these people at nasa have no idea what
they're doing
call the russians
we're going the lamb
we confirm shutdown jack lunar module
now in control roger that houston it
would get cold so fast from this moment
on we are improvising a new mission
oh come on sorry we'll get somebody to
look at that
everything's going wrong
damn it
we don't even know if the odyssey's
engine's even working and if there's
been serious damage to this spacecraft
they blow up and they die that is not
argument we are talking about time not
whether or not these guys come on i'm
not going to sugarcoat
let's hold it down
get a bunch of nerds in one room
together
[Laughter]
we expect loss of signal in less than
one minute when we pick you back up we
will have your pc
burn data okay roger that houston we'll
hear from you again at acquisition of
signal
you want to look
oh it's right in the reach their track
will have taught us
feeling buzz's old neighborhood
coming up on mount maryland
oh
you got to take a look at this
i've seen it
see it every night problem now is
not so much a question of an adequate
oxygen supply but it is the rate of
consumption of water which is vitally
needed for the cooling operation
man that worry really gets to me
[Music]
god damn that sucks man
stand by for your pc plus two burn data
gotta tell you i'd need to take this
baby down though
do some prospecting
gentlemen what are your intentions uh
[Music]
such a knee reversal he did it to earth
ken
what
good you're not dead oh my god he knows
nothing about any of this
[Music]
we can skip whatever we don't absolutely
need and turn things on in the right
order maybe
it's your ship we gotta get you in there
okay frank
i need the sim cold and dark give me the
exact same condition oh man
is this true what happened
like
bringing him in that's crazy
i hope this is true
this is wild effects yeah
running a temperature and none of them
has slept since ordered these guys to go
to sleep
did you sleep up there gonna get awful
cold in there for those guys
man that must be sleep deprived that's
wild we gotta find a way
to make this
fit into the hole for this
using nothing but that
[Music]
ah
only they could bring edibles
i think that make it worse
i've been going over the numbers again
are they called up with a re-entry plan
yet cause we're coming in too shallow
we're working on something check just
hold on
now you're supposed to be here
oh god damn it hey [ __ ]
this piece of shit's gonna get you old
all right that's cause that's the only
thing we got left jack
what are you saying bro well i think you
know what i'm saying
oh wait a minute goddamn the blame game
i'm not gonna go bouncing off the walls
for 10 minutes cause we're just gonna
end up right back here with the same
problems trying to figure out how to
stay alive aquarius this is houston are
we on vox no we're not unboxed
yeah houston this is aquarius go ahead
stress
a roll of gray
duct tape duct tape you need an lcd bag
two lcg bags
red suit hoses
so what is he having them do
uh a way to land again the to re reverse
it we're trying to figure out reentry
way
i think
[Laughter]
one thing they have too much of is
carbon dioxide with each breath the
three men expel more of the poisonous
gas into the lunar module cockpit and
the scrubbers intended to keep the
atmosphere breathable are quickly
becoming saturated
damn oh that's what they're doing
that's what they're doing
is
co2 canister select secondary all right
you assume the co2 level has dropped to
nine
and it is still falling
that is good to hear aquarius and you
sir are stealing missile man
all right which one has the leak don't
know that yet john which the sequence
was wrong we'd just have to go back and
try them one at a time
you need a break ken
if they don't get one i don't get one i
love him so much he is such a sweet guy
but now they're just going to
try to figure out a way to get them home
and it's a little bit dangerous
are you scared
well don't you worry honey
if they could get a washing machine to
fly
my jimmy could land
i am sick and tired of the entire
western world
knowing how my kidneys are functioning
[Music]
dwight i just lost level you died
[Laughter]
can't
spare power for the computer
uh houston without the computer what do
we use for orientation damn kevin bacon
looks like it's holding together really
well
that if this basketball where the earth
and this softball were the moon and the
two were placed 14 feet apart
the crew would have to hit a target
no thicker than this piece of paper
okay people on your toes i think i get
it so we're singing this doesn't look
good yeah
mark come on baby one more burn eight
seven
six
five
four oh let's just go
[Music]
yikes woohoo
[ __ ] she's dancing all over the place
come here the ride a little bit
15 seconds
i'm losing attitude
okay hold it right there no
freddie second bring the earth up
shut
houston we have shut down
that's close enough we're all still
friends here at houston you know what
how about that limb huh
how about it
guess you can keep your job you betcha
[Laughter]
this is green trail it's like a long
carpet that's just laid out right
beneath me and it was the algae right it
was just leading me home and now
you uh you never know what what events
are going to transpire to get you home
mm-hmm
this guy's like he's got this in the
back the performances are so good it's
like
oh [ __ ] dude
yeah you really believe that they're in
the scenario yeah they just play it's so
real
hello there deke what's the story jim
we're gonna get that power-up procedure
to you we're gonna get it as soon as we
possibly can ken mattingly's in the
simulator right now
ken's working on it can they that's
crazy reverse the flow and see if we can
draw these four amps from the lem
batteries before we cut it loose why
can't we do that we don't have a
procedure for that do we you're gonna
lose a lot in the transfer ken yeah yeah
but all we're talking about here is four
amps
i could have thought of that man
reverse the flow the la i love the
lemons yeah yeah
escape man it's easy you need to [ __ ]
re-simulate all the time
is your computer on now
up and running
i think we got it buddy
hey he should be the one to communicate
it yes he's really want to communicate
that's a negative jim
i don't have the measles
[Laughter]
blanche these nice young men are going
to watch the television with you this is
neil armstrong and this is holy [ __ ]
are you boys in the space program too
[Laughter]
master alarm off okay jack uh panel
seven b-mag number two power to warm up
make them sweat sweat sweat sweat
uplink completed
we got her back up ken
boy i wish you were here to see it
i'll bet you do
way to go jack
you followed instructions well
worst of all if the pyrotechnics that
control the parachutes have been damaged
the chutes may not open at all causing
the spacecraft to hit the water not at a
gentle 20 miles per hour but at a
suicidal 300. damn
is there anything good on the news
the house and senate passed resolutions
calling on the american people to pray
tonight for the astronauts in rome pope
paul led 50 000 people in prayers for
the safe return of the astronaut that's
why it's going to work
[Laughter]
it's about time to bail out of this
shift right now
oh no did he die dude
oh no
hold him man
a little while longer
we're gonna hit that water in the south
pacific it's 80 degrees out there
80
you got nothing to sweat
i love this performance man just like
try to keep it together this whole time
yeah
he's the glue
i'll look up at him
okay the pyro bats look good i don't
think we're gonna have to tie the other
batteries
what do you got to say man say what you
need to say
sorry jack it's an old habit
i'm kind of used to the pilot seat
she's yours to fly okay odyssey i want
to double check some
we jettison reentry procedures
put in his faith in him
she sure was a good ship
very well aquarius
and we thank you
aquarius got its ass kicked man
it's almost time honey
okay i don't i think i can watch
i just realized just tell me if they
land when will we know
blackout lasts for three minutes they're
not back in four
we'll know
that's the first black person i've seen
in this whole movie i don't even notice
i feel like this movie's been perfect
[Laughter]
be the worst disaster nasa's ever
experienced
with all due respect sir
i believe this is going to be our finest
hour
let's quit being a [ __ ]
[Laughter]
i expect entry interface in 45 seconds
35 seconds to entry interface
it's been a privilege flying with you
but i'm never doing this [ __ ] again
[Music]
holy god
we have loss of radial contact roger
that
expect to regain signal in three minutes
oh that's a terrible three minutes
yikes
for the command
the module heat of re-entry
if it doesn't there'll only be silence
mommy you're squishing me i'm sorry um
that's four minutes
standing by christ
now to see uh houston do you read
[Applause]
[Laughter]
hello houston this is honesty it's good
to see you again
[Laughter]
welcome home we're glad to see you
[Applause]
that's sweet
let it out man
let it out
[Laughter]
that was crazy they kept that all
last few minutes from the
from the world's perspective
[Music]
hi buckles it for him that's awesome
kevin bacon has been so chill
[Laughter]
this is apollo 13 signing on
[Applause]
we solved our [ __ ] up
[Applause]
in the following months it was
determined that a damaged coil built
inside the oxygen tank sparked during
our cryo stir oh my god
i wonder who put that there fred hayes
was going back to the moon on apollo 18
but his mission was cancelled because of
budget cuts oh
man
nor did jack swaggart who left the
astronaut court that's that man's last
congress from the state of
colorado but he died of cancer before he
was able to take office oh
jesus
mattingly orbited the moon as command
module pilot of apollo 16 and flew the
space shuttle having never gotten the
measles
and as for me
the seven extraordinary days of apollo
13 were my last in space i bet
i sometimes catch myself looking up at
the moon remembering the changes of
fortune in our long voyage
i look up at the moon
and wonder
when will we be going back
and who will that be we're not going to
see every night with his wife
come on well we're still
wondering well he still have not gone
back
i didn't realize his last name was
swaggered that makes so much sense now
i was touching his last name with kevin
bacon his last name was swagger yeah
oh [ __ ]
jack swagger
says his real name jack's i think it was
a t jack swaggart but swagger who's in
there he is a hollywood name
i wonder if there's a real name or not
right this is a real story i'm looking
it up right now
i love that and i liked it a lot that
was great reborn
it was a movie
you didn't like it
i respected it i respected it a lot man
i loved it i was so into it
ruining classic cinema here aaron never
invited back on the channel again after
today it was a very respectable
well-made movie
that's what i have to say got an
unpopular opinion
can't wait for you to rip it apart it
wasn't bad it was a bad movie i thought
it was i thought it was very well made i
thought all the performances were really
good this was my cup of tea but i
hear the one who picked it
technical and historical accuracy okay
here we go yeah it's based on a true
story okay oh yeah failure is not an
option failure's not a freaking option
said neil armstrong
[Laughter]
i like the singing this choir music
95 raw tomatoes 90 audience score wow
unpopular opinion
shame on you
listen i didn't say i didn't like the
movie i know that's what i hear it as
that's what the internet's gonna i hear
how i hear
i know i don't actually hear what you're
saying i hear how i hear with my ears
worst movie of the year no i'm just
kidding it's not it's not bad
it's very well made i have a lot of
positive things to say about we're
trying to justify your negative opinion
don't be a coward
if you hate it stick true to your to
your beliefs aaron for an after credit
don't i i'm legit checking to see if he
reunited with his wife
[Laughter]
there was a bummer i was watching this
going like hey the wife's
more
is written more than usual in these kind
of movies that's cool and then they
don't even unite them at the end
worst movie ever doesn't get a reunite
with his mount maryland i mean that's
what he's going to do when he gets back
home he's going to mount that marijuana
she's going to mount him sorry there
wasn't enough bang bang space action and
it's not star wars and lasers the [ __ ]
are my powers at man that's what it is
man you just gotta you don't appreciate
the
the the details cinema
yeah
yeah you're just you don't know you need
more jokes and comedy yeah it wasn't
punchy enough yeah yeah you didn't work
i need oscar isaac at the beginning
making a phone call to the big ship so
we can really you know punch out those
laughs you know
i needed a last jedi in here
that's what he did at the beginning of
the movie yeah yeah i remember that
movie now
[Laughter]
all right
well aaron hater of apollo 13.
bring it on bring it i know you didn't
hate the movie
um
i will let you uh make your defense
of my opinion
okay what i will say is i really dug
how the movie
built up the the tension of the mission
and all the things that go wrong
of the the of the course of the events
and i really dug the score of the movie
i thought everybody did a great job with
performances
tom hanks really held it down kind of
being that essential figure of the
person who's kind of been through a
scenario similar to this and
how he was kind of like the leader of
the three of them but i think for
for me
i'm a one of two
kind of
movie person
and it has there's no reflection of the
movie itself it's just my personal
experience and how i connect to movies
and it's either
through
like character
struggle and or
connecting to something personal to the
characters or through um
through like event kind of like
bombastic action or whatever but i'm
more of like a more of a character
person than like an event person i think
this is very a very technical film
and though i respect it i did really
um see all the steps and like before i
think for a long time for me it was like
is this the series of of things going
wrong to the thing that we know it's
eventually going to lead to them making
it and i was like that's cool like i i
can respect the the process i'm sure in
real life it's really scary kind of
going through all of those things
it just uh
i don't know it didn't didn't excite me
i i wasn't i didn't really know the
characters super well you know i feel
like bill paxton for the first half of
the movie didn't really talk all that
much and kevin bacon was super cool the
entire time
um but i can i can connect and
understand like
as a human why this is a big achievement
both
for the world for america
and all the people involved you know and
you you even though i wasn't emotionally
invested the entire time watching it i
definitely did feel at the end of the
movie like the the feeling of
satisfaction of like yeah they did it
you know so i think the the music really
aided with that plus seeing them kind of
go through this experience throughout
the course of the movie i don't know i
just thought it was a little slow
a little slow but you know i like i said
i respect it i think ron howard did a
great job of establishing all the things
that could go wrong in this scenario and
then watching it play out and the
tension of that
really showing
um
what what this experience could be like
you know what's it like in space for
your
ship to not work and then every time
they come back to earth it felt like it
was like okay like this is another
scenario like a blocker to them getting
back and then cut to the astronauts okay
this is another blocker for them getting
back but we know that they're going to
get back at the end so i was like okay
this is this is a ride but uh
yeah i don't know i just didn't uh fully
i wasn't like emotionally invested
within the characters themselves like
the three leads of the movie but
yeah i guess uh
it wasn't forced gum for me
but
yeah i guess that's i guess that's just
my opinion but i like i said i respected
it i think ron howard did a great job
music was very well
uh
done
yeah greg what'd you think what'd you
think of the movie i think you're a
[ __ ] aaron
this is perfect
uh
i definitely didn't have the same
experience you did
uh i i i felt like nor do i want to make
this a conversation where i'm just like
disagreeing with you
because yeah i i definitely got i i got
pretty emotional uh quite a bit and
i i was definitely on edge for a lot of
it i i think
i can understand why you're why
one's takeaway would be that i i could
see that
the opinion of i could definitely
understand the opinion of that for me i
think i just got a little bit of a
deeper reading of it because i'm more
intelligent than you in every corner of
life
i feel deeper listen as someone who just
did a video about unpopular opinions i
have i care less if you don't like this
movie or not
uh you know i just watched it like it
has no effect on me if you like this
movie or not
uh i think um
like to me the character was really in
the form of
it's a lot deeper than that more nuance
because
these three people especially tom hanks
is
is like from the very beginning you see
that his whole life is just an obsession
with
the with getting to the moon and being
able to you know
walk
walk the moon and in some ways kind of
hinting that he feels like he's a better
astronaut than neil armstrong even is
and that's his whole obsession
and what
what the real test of the characters are
is to prove that they're great
astronauts and that they're worthy is
not in the form
of all right we have a plan to go to the
moon and we're going to do it smoothly
and bam that will prove that we're great
astronauts it's proving themselves
through the perseverance and the
struggles and the knowledge and the
ability to improvise
in one of the craziest life or death
situations one can handle like that's
the testament to them being
great astronauts is that something went
terribly wrong
and even though they've completely
failed their mission
now it's about
here's what will make show what makes
them great astronauts right here and
also the willingness to
to really not give up i think uh the
tagline for this movie is failure is not
an option
so there is that intensity and i think a
lot of the performances they were going
i thought this movie had a great balance
because you got like different kinds of
space movies right
you you have like your big sci-fi
fantasy ones like a star wars or even
something like an interstellar which is
like science fiction right and
and then you have
uh
a movie like first man
which is there's the hyper realistic
version of this
and i thought
we might because while i never seen
footage of this film
i was just under the impression it might
be more like a gravity
you know where it's like
this [ __ ] ain't real
and i thought this had a great balance
of making a like a like a hollywood
rousing movie
backed with going for as much realism as
possible
but without it getting too bogged down
and
trying to be as realistic as possible
like i don't know what's true and what
isn't
so i think like with you know tom
hanks's character as he's like has these
nightmare you see like you own once he
has a nightmare and then every time he
has a big
he has a big
like the dream is right in front of him
like screw it land it we can go on the
moon and then he realizes like
everything he really has is not this
mission
everything he really has is back on
earth
you know that whole thing about
um look at mount maryland like i've
already seen it and then when he does
that thing
with the earth at the end you know
mirroring what he did with the moon like
this is
everything he has is back there and
that's what really matters to him and
not and not the moon as much as he
thought it did
so that's that's what counts and i think
the the performances were so strong
because
everything was so contained like it was
always the right amount of being on edge
while trying to keep it cool and then
you also got to play up the like i i'm
with you and i was making the jokes all
the time about like kevin bacon always
looked like he got ahead of [ __ ]
together like well bill paxton and tom
hanks always look like they were getting
progressively more tired and sick and
like kevin bacon's kind of looked like
kevin bacon
promotes like it's like a little bit a
little bit stressed you know
but for the most part i looked all right
physically
uh and you know he is the most in shape
one of them all
so i i think a lot of that was really
coming through those little character
moments there and so that's why i do
feel that the one thing that this movie
really robbed me of is that reunion with
his wife because so much of the emotion
that i felt
was
strung out of me wasn't seeing
the people back on earth and the the
worry and the fear like with the family
and what that must be like in that
condition you know of
i
this is this is their biggest fear this
is a life or death thing and i honestly
think that
you know
it's a real thing that people do they go
to space and i i take it for granted
that we can do that and
this really reminded me of yeah these
are there are like i like i love you
know gravity and inner stuff i actually
love those movies especially
interstellar i really love those films
and
uh and i like you know movies like first
man as well and then every once in a
while i see something that reminds me of
oh there is a great cost that could
occur from doing this
and um yeah so i i i felt like i got a
lot of the emotion from it and while
it's not as clear-cut of a character
piece
it's more of an observation of
who we are as people in a moment like
this because they're constantly
surrounded with we should just give up
or there's no possible way it's
constantly figuring out and i thought
there was a great the one who had the
best character written for me was gary
sinise
lieutenant dan and i thought he was
really well written because
you know like his performance was so
i'm used to seeing gary sinise play a
little bit more aggressive people like a
lieutenant dan or even his character
little appearance in green mile
or the villain in mel gibson ransom
another movie directed by ron howard now
that's a thrilling movie have you seen
ransom no no oh dude i think you would
totally dig that i love that movie it's
so good get me back my son uh
this is so good
damn i forgot ron howard did that till
right now oh that's a good movie anyway
um
yeah that uh
i i just like seeing how people are
changing through the course of the
immediacy of a situation
and so to me that was gripping enough
and with gary sinise
of
he i thought he just struck that right
cord of someone who definitely had
resentment towards being
ejected from the mission
he had this resentment but he tries to
be supportive and he still has that
yearning and longing and then he's able
to
still be a part of the mission in a way
that's more meaningful
that showed like there's purpose to the
fact that he wasn't able to go
you know because it's really if he
wasn't able to stay back and do the
simulations he wouldn't be able to
figure it out
so i thought that was actually kind of
beautiful i i liked it a lot
i'm part of the mainstream on this one
i'm not cool like you
i'm a hipster
now i uh i definitely see what you're
saying for sure like
persevering through failure or when you
don't actually achieve your dreams and
how do you how do you rebound from that
i think for for me those elements were
present i think the the technical
aspects of the mission
took
primary focus
for me in the story over those
uh personal aspects of persevering
through failure and i definitely like i
said i do
see them as present
i just um
yeah i don't know if that was like the
focus of the movie and like and he was
him being so driven and determined to
try to get there and like really being
super upset about
not being able to get to the moon or
like him having resistance towards the
fact that he wasn't able to get to the
moon i think i would have connected to
it a little bit more but i definitely
understand that those teams were there
and i thought it was there i mean he had
a whole vision a dream about that i'm
not saying that it wasn't there i said
it was there i don't know maybe the the
execution of it
didn't
like i said i think it's
it's a movie that it's
that it's very well made
um
yeah i just
it didn't excite me but
i appreciate it i respected it and it i
learned something new about history this
feels like a very
well-made history class movie
that's what i'll say
all right
uh so our friendship is effectively over
i understand
yeah yeah yeah i um
i was looking to sign the papers after
you know
you know just um
i didn't bring a pen though like do you
have you have extra pens for me to like
you are not allowed to use my pens okay
effective immediately okay i'll use my
own blood i'll like
i'll just get a stick and just like you
can simply leave
i mean that yeah that's an option and
walk into traffic
i like to run i just wanted to be over
with fast you know i want it to be a
slow painful death
because we do not share the same
emotional response
to apollo 13
because everybody knows if you're
watching a movie together you have to
have the same experience yeah no i mean
that's why marvel and dc fans get along
[Laughter]
no i i get it man no i don't i i
actually do completely i understand what
you're saying and as someone who has had
opinions about a movie that i'm like
everyone seems to love this
you hate winter soldier that's true
that's what i said in my video
said worst
worst makuu movie ever
[Laughter]
so yeah no i mean i i really appreciate
it i thought it was
i mean i thought at times like you
could have used like maybe one or two
scenes of them just really in the
in the dread and trying to talk and
maybe talking about like
or maybe bill paxton he's like maybe i
should give up you know i like kind of
that scene when they were starting to
argue with each other
i liked that scene that scene was really
good i like that like the characters
getting emotional scene but a lot of
it's about them keeping their cool and i
don't know i want to see some i want to
see some jazz i want to see some some
toxins i know you want to see some spice
and see some spices
like uh i i get what you're saying i
want to see ed helms punch somebody like
this is serious i mean ed harris at
harris
at harris point helms within this would
be very distracting and a little
annoying
[Laughter]
that helms not as funny as people
think that's your hot take
is he really that funny
did he hold down the office
not really
you know
[Music]
he was great in vacation
that was i never watched that movie the
turning point him freaking out in all
three of the hangover movies clearly the
highlight of all of them yeah he was
clearly the one
uh actually i do like it but uh it was
good but um
no i i think capture i think that that
kind of it's also like a masculinity
thing of the 60s i think as well you
know like with ed harris who's just so
he would have moments of outburst but
then even at the end it was like
it would make sense to me this guy
wouldn't fully cry like he would just
get a little tear i've seen some
emotional ass at her like the guy is not
incapable of bringing himself to an
emotional spot that's not the issue it's
it was a clearly a deliberate choice uh
to to like oh you know that he would
that guy would just shed a minimal tier
and
even on being on the mission it's like
you got i think they they have to stay
focused uh but you know in terms of like
a movie yeah i think i could have used a
tiny bit more of like
that of oh [ __ ] you know that the key to
them getting this mission done is they
have to keep it together
and they're falling apart as a group and
they have to i thought there was going
to be something a little bit more
with [ __ ] kevin bacon new guy on the
team like he's not they know him
obviously he's at the party at the
beginning and stuff so they have a
history with him but in terms of being
the the trio to do this
and there is that doubt that they have
of him
at the beginning when he's messing up in
the training i thought there was gonna
be something more to that you know like
i thought we would we only kind of
teased a little bit of that
with you know bill paxton
obviously kind of indicating that he
thinks he might be responsible for what
went wrong on this mission when they're
starting to blame
so i think kind of sitting in that dread
and
that and having some conflict there
because i think that our the emotional
scenes are a little bit like
spaced around like tom hanks comforting
uh bill paxton when he's freezing to
death or when tom hanks loses his [ __ ]
with like the [ __ ] sick of you
monitoring my meds in uh with a medical
unit yeah and so i think it's there and
i think the emote a lot of the emotion
comes from the at-home stuff you know
like with the
especially with especially with the wife
the scene with the grandma got me that
got me a little bit i gotta be very
emotional i was like i was like little
girl started crying i was like oh dude
that messed me up she's gonna be the one
that's i i do think i don't i i really
feel like that's such a missing piece as
the reunion with his wife and like
yeah we keep if we if we're not cutting
to nasa or the outer space we're cutting
to the wife
like she clearly has a whole journey
going on here
i would have liked the movie if you saw
his wife
i i think
could have changed things man
i don't understand why it sounded i i
don't understand the choice for why it's
not why we don't have that scene i i
don't get why we don't have that scene
ron howard was like no we don't need it
they don't care about that they care
about the mission i'm sure someone in
the comments is already explaining to me
thoroughly of why it's not necessary uh
go ahead do your thing helps the
engagement so yeah go for it
my personal
feeling is like i think that is
i i think that is a thing that this
movie i'm like no we need that we need
that reunion
so the whole movie that before that
she's like i don't think i can go to the
launch
i needed kevin bacon to reunite with
that girl at the beginning of the movie
that was my big takeaway hot girl at the
beginning hot girl at the beginning like
that
i tell you about how i came back from
failing my moon mission
i'm about to tell you
yeah i think
you know it would have been good well um
i really enjoyed it i'd love tom hanks
man that's not like i realize i've only
seen like his uh
his uh
i i want to see more of his ones that
are like after 2000
really yeah i'm like oh [ __ ] i haven't
seen philadelphia
i hadn't seen forrest gump i hadn't seen
grandma like i didn't like watch tom
hanks movies like what
what the [ __ ] like this has been a whole
discovery for me
i saw big i have seen big and i and i
think i saw splash something tells me
i've seen splash have you seen terminal
yeah that movie's great that movie
[ __ ] me up i've seen terminal i've
seen saving private ryan um
and uh
i've seen the polar express
[Laughter]
but captain phillips lady killers like i
i've i've knew i've ever seen larry
crown i i know of tom hanks movies more
than i've seen them but i'm like damn
like his biggest movies of the 90s other
than saving private ryan i hadn't seen
that's kind of shocking to me sleeping
in seattle sleeplessly i've seen the
business yeah you've seen the 90s one is
that 90s yeah oh was it yeah it's not
like a 80s it could be it could be
bullshitting i've seen all the i've seen
all the meg ryan i've seen the whole i
like joe versus the volcano and you've
got mail okay i've never seen those
i guess i just haven't seen his big
hard-hitting dramas in his best film
i haven't seen his best movies is what
i'm getting at
i still haven't seen philadelphia he won
the oscar for that
did he really i saw that it was uh him
and denzel right i've never seen that
one i saw pictures i'm like wow okay he
looks like he looks there's different
phases of him in this i'm like i wanna i
wanna check that out he won the oscar
for
i've always known him my whole life he
won the oscar for philadelphia
and very i i he might
i could be way wrong about this
um i'll correct you yeah
feel free correct me if anything he's
one of very few people to have pulled
this off especially when the oscars
actually meant something
he won the oscar for philadelphia and
then the very next year he won for
forrest gump really yeah wow i know
christoph waltz
was in glorious bastards and django
i don't think they were the like one
year apart it might have been a couple
years apart no yeah
um but
but uh
but yeah he won like two years in a row
yeah because in glorious bastards 2009
and django's 2012.
actually tom hanks and christoph walton
are moving together has that been done
that'd be so very cool i want to see it
now
can you think about that as a combo i
think yeah i think tom hanks he's such a
he has such a natural charisma to
himself and he doesn't look like your
typical leading man at all no and so
that's what's like kind of cool about
tom hankston is he he does look like
your everyday kind of guy
and he had he doesn't really even have
those like classic hollywood leading man
looks you know he's got like super kind
of like balding head
a little bit of hair up here a little
bit of weird smile yeah he felt like a
very distinct look about himself but
he's he's a great leading man he really
is a great leading man he's a fantastic
actor so
uh yeah i i think um i enjoyed this
movie a lot sorry you didn't
i i didn't hate him let me just indulge
you earn i was if i had to put it on a
10 scale i'd say it was a 7 out of 10
for me that's not bad you should have
led with that
i said i said i respected the movie
people wouldn't have thought you hated
this film
the whole time i'm happy that the
critics love it i really am wow that's a
lot of red tomatoes
let's go to the audience
okay look jamie c on rotten tomatoes
agrees with you
it's good in places but dull and others
there we go
all right okay i'm sorry i'm just
getting past all these five-star reviews
oh these perfect oh there's one negative
one it's in spanish can't read it um
okay four and a half
i don't really like long scenes in space
but that was nice
sounds like an opinion aaron would have
oh god
sorry i have five stars i like gravity
like he was good most of these are just
five stars
okay look eugene said uh this film was
somewhat tedious and especially boring
if you two are fed up of america saves
the day films you almost certainly
dislike this film
okay i'm not that i'm not that best off
opting the modern takes on life in space
which provided much more interesting
actually did you see that they they were
able to
to um
they developed the device because they
thought space has no sound but there is
a sound emitted so they develop a device
where you can hear the sound of space
what and uh i think it's from like
collecting all the gases from space and
it is like a
haunting noise it is like a terrifying
noise it feels like you're in the vortex
of hell
with my headphones on i was like this is
a really unsettling sound i don't think
i want to hear this anymore
guys it's really hard to find these uh
low star reviews uh oh here i got
another one after many five-star ones
from the audience not critics just
regular people you know voting it's not
all that great it's just another
mediocre film with not much
it just skip and watch something else
like the 1983 film the right stuff
i like the guy after him
never tell awesome that's the odds never
tell this
um hold on go there's another one that
was like that was me this is like well
made space movie where is it
three stars well made period piece space
exploration film
boom
there you go
man i was in the edge of my seat you
tried [ __ ] going to space and dealing
with you
guarantee one one trip i would die five
seconds up in the air he'd be like this
is the most terrifying thing i would
[ __ ] myself i get very like i see past
the filmmaking with space stuff and i
get really thrusted into
the feeling of being in like what it
must be like to be in space so when
something goes wrong i'm like
that's very uncomfortable
i i i it easily plays on an unsettled
feeling for me
so yeah i'm very easily manipulated by
it you have more empathy than me
i do
i could have used it without that one
scene with a black guy i felt like they
were trying to placate to what culture
though you know what i mean yeah yeah no
that was the only thing that i felt seen
like i was the only yeah my people it's
like shoehorn shoehorned in
i felt that was the 60s nasa was racist
[Laughter]
his grandma definitely hated black
people yeah
oh for sure anyway
uh anyway we're done
we're done here thank you guys for being
here
um you could go hate aaron on social
media hate me
and he's writing a think piece about why
you're wrong for liking apollo 13. yeah
all of you guys
are trash
and the superior one because i know how
movies are supposed to be
i know the first thing about making a
movie
as someone who's made never made a movie
before i know exactly how to do it
thank you guys for being here we'll
catch you guys soon
[Music]